how was your whenever Aaron Rodgers came
through how was that was that pretty
what was something what was that like he
was the coolest so we probably had 30 or
40 guests on my show he was
the the number one coolest dude that you
I didn't know what to think about I mean
I had you on the show but I had met you
a bunch of times before
he was the coolest guy that just didn't
know what I was gonna get he he could
not have been
he had this huge house
we did Lake Tahoe at this golf
tournament and
this is actually a good story so I have
like Bookers that's how I get my show
most of the time sometimes I'll know the
person or sometimes they'll hit me up or
I'll hit them up on like Instagram but
most of times it's a girl named a woman
named Kelly and uh another woman named
Peggy who from our booking department
who like put everything together so
Peggy books Aaron Rodgers on my show and
we get a list I don't know how it is for
your pod but it's like I get a list of
like would you be interested in these
people yes and I always just circle like
the best ones I don't even I just only
like Aaron Rodgers Tom Brady you know
and I never get any of them yeah or at
least I hadn't got any of them in the
past and then I got a message or email
was like hey Aaron Rodger will do your
show and I was like no way really it's
like awesome there was gonna be too much
for men at the Lake Tahoe golf
tournament because she's on like a Greek
vacation or something
so we get to the tournament
and we're out there in Lake Tahoe I
don't know if you've been but it's a
hard place to get to you've got to fly
to Reno you got to fly cross-country
flight of Reno and then drive yeah yeah
and so we're out there it's not an easy
place to get to beautiful drive say the
shoot's on a Tuesday I don't remember
the shoot's on like a Tuesday
and it's Monday yeah and we're like what
time and where is this thing gonna
happen and then um Peggy who's our
Booker is like hitting up his agent or
whatever
and we're going to get back to he's
doing this doing that and then finally
at night they're just like uh we're
gonna be honest with you we haven't
talked to Aaron in two months the agent
he doesn't answer any of our calls
like Aaron Rodgers saying it's like he
got to the Packers offensive coordinator
yeah right like he just lives in his own
existence like he just is in this he's
in this lane or this like wave that he's
just riding yeah and that's kind of how
you feel when you're around him he's
just kind of like he's just on his own
wavelength and he just didn't talk to
his agent for two months so I'm out
there I'm like what I'm gonna do and
actually shout out to big uh Pat McAfee
oh that's awesome who worked at Barstool
and I was like Pat I hate to call in a
favor ever
and I would it
I don't know how I could repay you
especially you've got what freaking 2
billion dollars now and all the access
in the world is on every show but I was
like I really here's the situation
um Rogers agreed to do the show it's not
like
it's not like I'm asking you to ask
Rogers to do it he said he would do it
right but we just don't know where he's
at we can't locate him mystery and so
Pat talk to Rogers who he responded with
Pat and he was like show up at his house
this time tomorrow
so we get in there he the whole timer
with him he doesn't take his he doesn't
have shoes on the whole time yeah and
he's just like that's a move right there
he just in his I don't even know how to
explain he's just cool like he's
old-fashioned cool like you're around
him like this is a cool guy
and he was awesome on the interview and
then they give y'all sodas or anything
he had a full staff he had like a full
wow
like they made us drinks I we had went
out the night before I think I was like
a little hungover and he was like you
need a drink I think he saw it in my
eyes like you want to drink and I was
like yeah I would take a drink so it was
a staff like made me like a margarita
and we did the interview it was awesome
and then we hung out meet him and
Glennie balls for like seven hours no
yeah just sitting on his porch talking
and I asked him every question I mean I
don't want to like
yeah yeah go too much into it but I
asked him every question that you could
think of asking why like off the Record
like off the Record what do you think of
this and he was super transparent honest
answered every question questions you
can't even believe would be answered by
anybody and he was just awesome dude he
was just
I kind of have a man crush on him I
guess I don't know that's what that's
what it's sounding like I think he's is
a stud he's just really a stud okay and
is he handsome does he seem Handsome
when you're around him I think he's
traditionally probably I think he's in
the upper tears of handsome but I think
I think he would probably say he's
he's Beyond he's like a Beyond Burger
for a handsome like oh damn
he's a he but he's the real deal you
don't think about him being attractive
when you're looking when you're with him
you think about like this is
this is just like a I'm a football fan
too so like you know what he's done on
the field and like you know how good he
is or what he does yeah and then just so
how it could be that cool too and be on
your own lane he's super
authentic hmm
or that he is now I mean I don't know
how he used to be before the Ayahuasca
or before his whole like diff I mean I
think he's went through a lot of stuff
yeah right he seems like a journeyman he
seems like a man who's almost traveled
time now when I look at him yeah and he
probably has when you left him that day
did you feel like did you miss him yeah
I text him right afterwards and I was
like we saw like a vaccination sign like
must be vaccinated I said I said you
can't come here you know he just text
about like immunized bro yeah and
Glennie balls feels the same way he's uh
Cleveland Ball's gonna kill me for
saying this he's Glenn Ball's background
on his phone him Glennie balls like this
he's going his background on his phone I
think it's sweet man you know it's hard
to find good male figures out there in
the world these days
um especially athletes too because it's
been for a long time like
I mean you're a huge sports fan and so
am I it's like for pretty much our whole
lives athletes haven't been able to
while they're playing especially just
like say wild [ __ ] and be like really
good and have thought behind it I mean
here are some guys say some wild [ __ ]
yeah but it's like they just didn't
think about it they accidentally said it
right but he's like I don't care
yeah and you know his his fan base is
every type of person every demographic
probably from multi-countries and he
just he just saying his truth and it's
kind of cool that's what's so cool yeah
it seemed like he has like he's like a
six shooter like it wouldn't be
surprised if he pulled out a six shooter
same yeah I mean he is he just shot a
bunch of [ __ ] cool ass [ __ ] ideas
into the world no bullets I wonder what
he'll do after football oh
you know I got did he talk about
ayahuasca
um when I was with him it was before his
announcement that he had done it right
and he was like I'm about to say
something he's like he told me he's like
I'm about to do this uh announcement
that's going to be pretty controversial
and I'm an idiot and he was like what
what is it he's like well just that I've
been using a little plant medicine and I
was like and I was like
I was like I was like we all know
I told him I was like dude everyone
knows that you've [ __ ] taken
ayahuasca he's like you think I was like
everyone knows dude trust me it's like
they won't even make a blip on the news
and he says it was like every news story
I was like dude no one cares everyone
knows don't worry about it yeah
yeah I got actually because Aubry uh uh
Aubrey Marcus invited me to go I was
supposed to go on that trip when they
went and you didn't go I had a show book
somewhere [ __ ] it was in I think Tulsa
and it had been sold out for like four
months I just felt like it I couldn't
I mean I could have maybe sent a mass
email to those people
it said like hey guys I'm thinking about
doing this you know I don't know but if
if like 50 of them said no we wanted to
see the show I probably would have done
this dude I honestly if you want to live
stream you and Aaron do an Ayahuasca
they've probably been okay yeah if I
could have sold tickets to that dang
yeah man but he was I mean I I don't
know if I butchered talking about it but
he is as cool of a guys I've ever met
in in any Walk of Life is very very cool
to be around
no I think it's interesting man because
you always kind of like he's
he seems a little bit like he doesn't
seem like a company man that's what I
like about him no I can see how he'd be
frustrating to play with or definitely
to coach yeah you would but at this
point of his career you kind of Coach a
rattler you don't want to coach him a
smart one yeah who's probably better at
being a rattler than you are yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I don't understand how
any good quarterback has a quarterback's
coach who was not a good quarterback
most of them are in play ever
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one